one of the things I like doing the most
is just exposing the hypocrisy or the
ignorance and the bigotry of
conservatives and usually I wouldn't
bring up someone like Tammy Lauren I'm
sorry Tommy Lauren but I want to bring
her up because of a tweet that she sent
out last night more specifically not
because of what she said but the reality
of the hypocrisy that that she exists in
regularly on Twitter this is what she
had to say quote we owe illegals nothing
not housing not healthcare not education
nothing now before I get to the response
from a candidate for a House seat in
Virginia by the name of Kasim Rashid I
want to point out the overwhelming just
actually I'm sorry just the lies and the
deception that is placed around
quote-unquote illegals coming to the
country which is a term that they use
specifically to make to to to make them
seem it's called the other patient to
make people afraid of them their car
illegals right but the what Tommy's
trying to convey here is that the same
tired conservative talking point that
illegals quote unquote illegals for
people listening on the radio are taking
from our society in reality there's a
study that shows that undocumented
workers which in many cases this this is
who they're referring to these are
workers who come to this country they
actually work they actually pay taxes
and they are a net benefit to our
economy the Institute on taxation and
economic policy found that undocumented
immigrants contribute significantly to
state and local taxes collectively
paying an estimated eleven point six
four billion dollars a year they went on
to say that undocumented immigrants
nationwide pay an average and S on
average an estimated eight percent of
their incomes and state and local taxes
as opposed to the top one percent of
taxpayers who pay an average of just
five point four percent so yes you read
that right you heard that correctly
undocumented workers pay a higher
percentage
of their income in state and local taxes
than the top 1% so this this line that
all conservatives use that Tammy is just
the most recent that they are takers
from our society when actually in
actuality they are net benefits to our
society at least according to the study
of on Institute and taxation and
economic policy some of their key
findings from 2016 that's just part one
I want to talk about the hypocrisy on
top of the fallacy Kasim Kasim Rashid
quoted Tammy on Twitter and this is what
he said quote reminder Lauren's
great-great-grandfather Constantin
Dietrich was indicted for forging his
naturalization documents Laurens
great-great-grandfather Gilbert halvard
Lauren also came via fraud since Tommy
Tommy is the descendant of the
quote/unquote illegals she hates so much
why when does she self-deport okay the
last part is cute but the important
thing here is the level of hypocrisy
that comes from conservatives with
regards to immigration policy in general
setting aside the derogatory term of
illegals in fact so many Republicans
conservatives white Americans simply
walk through Ellis Island right mmm what
percentage of conservatives are only
second generation third generation
fourth generation at best right so many
of them came through at a time when our
immigration policies were genuinely what
you see on the Statue of Liberty give us
your tired your your weary well they
benefit from these loose immigration
policies of America's history but once
they started seeing the Browning of
America which is not my phrase I didn't
coin it I remember it most from Bill
O'Reilly when he was speaking to a
matter of fact I guess we have to play
that clip Pat drop that clip right about
now but do you understand what the New
York Times wants and the far left want
they want to break down the white
Christian male power structure of which
you are a part
so am i and they want to bring in
millions of foreign nationals to
basically break down the structure that
we have and so he's speaking to the
quote unquote Browning of America and
once they saw that the immigration
policy started to allow for the quote
unquote
Browning of America all of a sudden they
had a problem with immigration of every
type but they also had a problem
specifically with undocumented workers
for which many of the corporations in
this country benefit so so the hypocrisy
there's so many layers of hypocrisy here
but the fact of the matter is is that
it's all a fraud it's all a lie it's all
an effort it's just the politicization
of human lives for the purposes of cheap
political wins playing on these fears of
the Browning of America
in other words America is going to lose
power the the general power structure
like Bill O'Reilly just said of white
Christian men is going to be challenged
because you have so many quote-unquote
illegals coming over the border it has
nothing to do with resources it has
nothing to do with giving them health
care has nothing to do with give them
education especially when we see based
on the Institute on taxation and
economic policy that undocumented
immigrants paid eight percent of their
incomes in state and local taxes as
opposed to the top one percent so who's
really taking something from America